well today's news conference held by
planned parenthood governor steve
sisilak and other state leaders just
wrapped up this all in response to
today's historic decision by the u.s
supreme court to overturn roe v wade now
sasha loftus joins us live this
afternoon in north las vegas with more
sasha
christian yes as you mentioned that
press conference just wrapped up local
leaders state leaders here just really
voicing their opinions and voicing their
reactions after today's historic
decision we have democratic senator
jackie rosen here with us thank you so
much for joining us and you kind of
shared this during today's press
conference but what was your general
reaction to today's news well thank you
for having me but let me tell you it is
devastating news it is devastating to
women girls across this country
my daughter woke up this morning and had
less rights
than she had yesterday and less rights
than i've had for nearly 50 years of my
life so it's really important that we
find a way to codify roe v wade to be
sure that women have the right to make
their own reproductive choices to be
sure that women don't die if they show
up in emergency room with an ectopic
pregnancy or a miscarriage there's so
many things that we have to protect a
young child a victim of rape or incest
and so we really have to do everything
we can to mobilize organize expand our
democratic pro-choice majority in the
senate to protect the lives of women all
across this country and you were
speaking of the importance of people
getting out and voting on either side of
the aisle and nevada is one of nine
states where abortion is protected under
the state constitution so if you could
just kind of speak a little bit about
the importance in your opinion of
getting out to vote here at the local
level and really all around the country
i think it's important that we work at
our local state and federal level and
although we do have roe v wade we have
it codified here into law
let's be clear
if you have a mag of republican for
governor
they can do a lot of things to try to
restrict access to abortion if you don't
reelect senator catherine cortez masto
and you have someone like mega
republican adam laxalt who has
cheered on this as a big victory and
wants to impose a nationwide ban on
abortion a nationwide ban on women's
rights
then you have to mobilize organize and
get out and vote in november and beyond
it matters
thank you so much again democratic
senator jackie rosen joining us today
after today's emergency press conference
put on by planned parenthood